can we just no one seems to want to talk
to the British press about Briggs it
when will article 50 be triggered this
man
michelle bali a chief EU negotiator on
brexit lost in his own building as he
prepares the biggest bill in british
history are you gonna have a good
breakfast and walking straight into Sky
News on the way in to the EU summit
million brexit bill mr. Bernier no
answer on the issue that's set to
dominate early deal-making after article
50 is triggered it was Sky News who at
the last European summit revealed that
mr. Barney's team had been discussing
with diplomats and EU leaders about this
fifty billion pound bill to be presented
to the UK at the start of negotiations
and EU leader was willing to confirm
early thinking on this thorny issue when
you sign on for contracts who you could
beat yourself to participation and are
billions and obviously the extent of
that that level of of money will be
determined Mr Bond yay here's the lead
negotiator for the European Union
and obviously BRIC will have a state
brexit not on the formal agenda at this
brand-new egg-shaped 300 million euro
Brussels summit HQ so the charm
offensive can continue for now but many
leaders anticipate a different EU out of
the brexit process and much tougher days
in this room Teresa may may have hoped
to leave her domestic issues behind but
not after that budget arriving here
their main topic of conversation polish
domestic politics whilst the EU has to
discuss a myriad of other crises it does
raise the question exactly what sort of
European Union while Teresa may be
negotiating with after she triggers
article 50 Poland's squabble over Donald
Tusk ended with him being
comprehensively re-elected Britain
likely to be the problem child at the
next meeting at home Breck City is
furious about the notion of that exit
bill legally we don't have any
obligation to pay a damn thing but my
point is what this is all about it is
about the negotiation so as the Germans
have said you can't expect the British
to accept that they
Oh any money if they don't know what the
arrangements are afterwards there's
never been quite as big an elephant in a
room as bricks it's in this shiny new
summit hall but soon enough
the real talk begins Faisal Islam Sky
News in Brussels